-Welcome, everybody. Welcome.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
What a show we have for you.
What a show we have
for you tonight.
Tom Hiddleston and Brie Larson
are my guests tonight.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's right. Loki and
Captain Marvel are here.
I got to say,
going to Comic-Con is fun,
but it's even more fun
when it comes to you.
You know what I'm saying?
Come on.
That's right.
Loki is here tonight.
And speaking of
the God of Mischief,
former President Trump
is in the news.
That's right, Trump's classified
documents trial is coming up,
and I read that prosecutors
may call for testimony
from workers at Mar-a-Lago,
including a plumber, a maid,
a chauffeur and a woodworker.
So clearly, Trump hid his
documents in the toilet,
the closet, the car,
and Eric and Don Jr's treehouse.
That's right, a plumber, a maid,
a chauffeur, and a woodworker
could be called
to testify against Trump.
And we actually got our hands
on the plumber's interview
with the lawyers.
-Really?
-Yeah, listen to this.
[ Crowd groans ]
-Oh, hey.
-What?
-What is...?
-Why would he ask that?
-Why?
-That seems ridiculous.
I don't know why he asked.
It seems what?
-Ri-dic-ulous.
[ Rim shot ]
-Well, changing subjects --
people are talking about this.
New York City Mayor Eric Adams
is under investigation
for receiving
illegal campaign donations,
and apparently,
the FBI just seized his phones.
Yeah.
Everyone was like,
"Phones? Plural?
Oh, yeah. He's guilty."
Yeah, phones?
When New Yorkers heard
about the news about the mayor,
just out of habit, they were
like, "friggin' de Blasio."
What?
Hey, guys, this is exciting.
The 2024 Grammy nominations
were announced today.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And some of the top nominees,
including SZA,
the "Barbie" soundtrack,
and Taylor Swift.
Taylor has
a bunch of nominations.
Let's just say that she could
become the first artist
to break 10,000 steps
at an award show.
It's crazy,
this year, Taylor Swift
could win a Grammy,
an Oscar, and the NFL MVP.
All three.
No one's ever done it.
Speaking of Taylor,
a man in Maryland
started a Taylor Swift jar
that his wife had to put
a dollar into
every time
she mentions Taylor Swift.
Well, it turns out
a lot of people have jars
to get them to stop
doing certain things.
I'll show you what I mean in
a new segment called
Other Jars.
-♪ Other jars, other jars ♪
♪ Now it's time
for other jars ♪
-First up, Mitch McConnell
has to put a dollar in his jar
every time he starts buffering.
-♪ Other jars ♪
-Next up, Chip and Joanna Gaines
have to put a dollar
in their jar
every time they say
the word "shiplap."
-♪ That's another jar ♪
-Here's the next one.
Joe Biden has to put
a dollar in his jar
every time he calls
a 70-year-old "kiddo."
-♪ I call that another jar ♪
-Yeah, and finally,
here's the last one,
Gerry, the Golden Bachelor,
has to put a dollar in his jar
every time he makes you ugly cry
by just being himself.
That's it for "Other Jars."
No. That's all.
That was the last one.
-♪ Come on, man,
just one more jar ♪
-Uh, okay. Here's one.
Ron DeSantis has to put
a dollar in his jar
every time he stands
on his tippy toes
to see the options at Chipotle.
-♪ One more jar ♪
-No, another?
I really don't have any more.
There's no more jars.
-♪ One more jar ♪
-No more jars.
-The bit is over. I'm sorry.
-[ Deep, rattling voice ]
♪ You must give me ♪
♪ One more jar ♪
♪ I am all powerful ♪
♪ Deliverest me thou jar
or perish! ♪
-Alright, alright.
Okay, okay. Uh...
Donald Trump has to put
a dollar in his jar
every time he shows up to court
and asks to meet Judge Judy.
-♪ That is all for Other Jars ♪
-Whew.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And finally, everybody,
the Census Bureau just announced
that the world population
has topped 8 billion.
So on behalf of everyone,
I just want to say
thank you to Nick Cannon.
We have a great show tonight.
-Give it up for The Roots!
Come on!
[ Cheering ]
♪ Dogs at my doorstep
will come around ♪
♪ Go around like the vortex ♪
♪ Competition, I'm all for it,
quartet ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, everybody.
As I said, Grammy nominations
came out today,
just this afternoon.
And I want
to say congratulations
to our very own Tariq Trotter,
who got nominated for a Grammy!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
-Tariq got nominated
for Best Rap Performance
for your song "Love Letter."
Congratulations, buddy.
Come on. Black Thought!
Black Thought, right there!
Come on!
Congratulations.
That's how you do it.
That made me happy. Come on.
I also want to mention,
all next week,
you're going to see
how I arrive to work every day,
when I walk in the building.
-Really?
-It's a new thing, like they do
with the NBA players
in the arena?
-Right.
-Yeah, it's very similar to me,
right down
to some of my outfits.
Anyway, it's going to be
"Tonight Show" Entrance Week.
-Ooh, wow.
-So tune in for that.
-The whole week?
-Yeah, the whole week.
But first, what a show
we have for you tonight.
He is an Emmy
and Tony-nominated actor
whose series "Loki" is now
streaming its second season
on Disney Plus.
Tom Hiddleston is here!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, she's an Oscar winner
who you can see in the Apple TV+
series "Lessons in Chemistry,"
and her new film
"The Marvels"
opened in theaters today.
Brie Larson is joining us.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Plus, he is a comedy legend,
one of my favorite
comedians ever.
He wrote the musical "Spamalot,"
which is back on Broadway
at the Saint James Theater.
Eric Idle is here,
ladies and gentlemen.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we got great music tonight,
Rick Ross and Meek Mill.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, today is Friday,
and that's usually
when we catch up
on some personal stuff.
I check my inbox,
return some emails,
and of course
I send out thank you notes.
And I was running a bit behind.
Is that okay?
Can I write out
some thank you notes now?
I appreciate that.
James, can I get some
thank you note-writing music,
please?
[ Gentle music playing ]
♪♪
Thank you, Ohio,
for legalizing
recreational weed.
[ Cheering ]
Wait, you're telling me
a state known for eating chili
on top of spaghetti just now
legalized weed?
-Come on, Ohio.
-Thank you,
the "Golden Bachelor"'s
Women Tell All episode
for starting with a warning
that the show may be disturbing
to viewers under 65.
Thank you, Election Day,
for forcing all of us
to make exceptionally
important decisions
in our old high school
gymnasium.
Thank you,
apartment smoke detector,
for alerting me
there's a fire by doing
a Mariah Carey impression.
Thank you, autocorrect,
for waiting until
the exact second I hit "send"
to ruin a message.
Thank you,
Pizza Hut Hong Kong's
new snake pizza
for being the first time
a delivery guy says,
"Who ordered the snake pizza?"
and it's not
the start of a porno.
You guys, we --
There you have it.
Those are our thank you notes.
We'll be right back with
Tom Hiddleston, everybody!